hello everyone and welcome back to
rotten tomatoes is wrong i am mark i was
joined as always by my delightful
co-host jacqueline coley and jacqueline
you know you get to do these kind of
episodes once you get past the 100
benchmark you know because like we've
been waiting to do this is this might be
the most highly anticipated episode in
rotten tomatoes wrong history but before
we get to that you and i are just
freshly back from san diego comic-con
what was your what was your favorite
part of the weekend everything uh that
was said after those drummers came out
for the black panther portion of the
marvel panel i'm just gonna call it the
black panther panel because i know like
there were other people there and other
things happen
it was just the black panther panel as
far as i was concerned it was the black
panther weekend
all we care about so it was a pretty it
was pretty great moment i i feel like
jacqueline and i had the best comic-con
interaction you could possibly have
because we never i did the math we never
actually
yeah spoke to one another but jaclyn was
in the audience for something i was
doing and i was in the audience for
something jacqueline was doing so we saw
each other on the lighted stage and that
kids sometimes is enough and honestly in
this industry that is real friendship
the fact that we showed up and you
showed up for your friend texted them as
you're leaving i was at your thing bye
you did good here's the pic
here's proof that i was in
the audience bearing witness to you
walking the boards and um yeah and so
and so now we're back and we're in our
respective home studios getting to do rt
is wrong again and like i said there's
episodes you're excited to do there's
episodes about big time movies and then
there's the ones that everybody is
waiting they are just waiting with
baited breath for you to finally
announce and it is here today we're
talking about a goofy movie from 1995
rated g it is 70 on the audience score
which is fine news barely fresh on the
tomato meter 61
and we have a very special guest joining
us here today who also was at comic-con
doing all the things hosting stuff uh
walking around mingling death all the
the the best parties and now she's back
home doing what she does best which is
everything from acting to writing you've
seen her in a disney movie you've seen
her in ralph breaks the internet you
know her from writing on for netflix hbo
max she just had a dc comics run with
harley quinn she is also the mother of
maui the one the only miss danny
fernandez is in the virtual building
danny we finally did it we got you on
the show whoa i have campaigned for this
so much it's wild i was just saying we
don't need to do a fan email because i
can just let people look at the text
messages slight
first invitational then bordering on
slightly threatening towards the end
from miss danny fernandez being like
when we doing goofy like and then
towards the end it was just goofy
question mark and like
anger emoji back when i was like girl we
working on it
oh i i just want to convey because i
guess people not everyone knows that
this is a cult
classic this is something that just blew
up in a way that it was a sleeper in the
90s um i'm sorry if it didn't resonate
with people that were older but those of
us that grew up in the 90s it was like a
massive thing and then it had a
huge like reunion and comeback and you
could get power line shirts at target
and now disneyland has all this stuff i
mean they've taken notice and so that's
the only thing is i always try to tell
people like even if you're on the
outskirts of this there is a massive
following for it um and that's it's just
such a it's a cult movie it's
iconic 90s disney movie very iconic 90s
disney we're going to be talking about
today because a goofy movie has a lot of
different elements to it like danny said
it's a beloved classic in some eyes it's
just a movie that came out to other
folks before we get into our feelings
about the tomato meter which again is 61
fairly fresh jaclyn i turn it over to
you for the synopsis what is a goofy
movie about the tagline for the film is
it's hard to be cool when your dad is
goofy yeah it's hard to be a goof is
basically the sentiment of a goofy movie
because in this we fall follow goofy
goof who is our the goofy that we know
from the comics and his son max goof and
basically max is raised by his single
parent dad and he is trying to woo the
very lovely roxanne who danny is very
closely cosplaying today with the braids
and the shirt i've i i spotted that but
basically yeah it's like the last day of
school max is trying to woo uh roxanne
he wants to take her to the to the big
the big thing he's like i'm gonna show
her how cool i am i'm just like
powerline but he's a goof so he's goofy
and everything and the worst thing he
ever wants to be is just like his dad we
open literally the movie with him
talking about how much he does not want
to be his dad and how he just really
wants to root roxanne and so instead
goofy decides to take him on a road trip
and anything you know about father-son
road trip there's gonna be a happy
family moment so goofy is essentially
the villain of this because he is trying
to rip max away from roxanne and make it
more like him and take him on this
adventure but through the course of
adventure and through some lovely songs
that sort of culminates in powerline
which is basically a mix between m.c
hammer and bobby brown and a little bit
of prince
that is where they come together and
they realize he can be a little goofy he
can be a little cool but he'll always be
goofy's kid very heartwarming father-son
moment and yeah and that's the end of
the goofy movie it is literally one of
the most perfect movie musicals ever
created i mean look in this in this
podcast i will discuss
i uh we're seeing eye to eye here
jacqueline but we're gonna turn it over
to danny fernandez first for the
question at hand which is danny
the tomato meter 61 for a goofy movie is
rotten tomatoes wrong about a goofy
movie ron tomatoes is so wrong about
this film i honestly if it's not a
hundred percent i would say it should at
least be 95
this is one of the most uh perfectly
made disney movies it is like jaclyn
said super heartwarming has a
tremendously amazing original soundtrack
that you are right they try to combine
prince and michael jackson tevin
campbell nailed it knocked it out of the
park it is those songs are so catchy and
iconic um and yeah it has the title
character i mean it has goofy you know
that we all grew up with but also you
see
mickey and a couple of other donald you
see a couple of other uh iconic disney
characters that pop in there but yeah
this is just
uh universal i want to say this is a
universal experience of being
embarrassed by your parents trying to
impress your crush and having to go on a
trip with them when you're just i think
it's hilarious jacqueline that you said
goofy is the villain because if you
watch this as an adult you're like okay
max is a brat and his dad just wants to
get close and take care of him he's a
single father and he's heartbroken over
the fact that his teenage son wants
nothing to do with him absolutely but at
the time he was villainous because there
was nothing worse as a teenager than
being for sure now with your parents
also i might add that i learned
something very depressing which is that
you spend 90 percent of the time with
your parents before you turn 18.
wow
after that time you only spend 10 with
your parents and if you don't have
children it is even less well i mean
okay i'll accept that because i'm not
gonna i'm not gonna have a kid just so i
can hang out with my mom more my mom and
i get to see each other plenty um
jacqueline it seems like you're on the
same page as danny do you feel rotten
tomatoes is as wrong as miss fernandez
does this is gonna be so weird i don't
think there was a movie that i felt
rotten tomatoes was more wrong about
than constantine just because i'm like
stacked up against other things so what
you're going to get is like movie nerd
deep dive on a goofy movie because in
addition to re-watching it because this
is the best thing about this movie and
lovely danny cummings she also selected
a movie that was only an hour in 10. so
you best believe i queued that stuff up
on netflix because i was like i mean on
disney plus because i was like i need to
watch this i'm gonna like watch the
whole thing i wanted to dance when
powerline happened but really looking at
it now through my post and kanto post um
generational trauma disney this movie
was so ahead of its time it's the disney
that we have today they just did it 25
years earlier and when you like hear the
history of like carter burrell and
menken and sort of the architect of the
golden age of disney and how this was
really an homage to what we had already
lost girl let me just tell you this is
it's it's about to be everything yeah i
mean it came out back in 95 and so it
was a movie that i missed and we'll get
into the reason why i missed it at the
time uh many reasons why i missed it at
the time but for me i'm gonna say ron
tomatoes is wrong i feel like this movie
definitely deserves much more praise
than it got at the time from the critics
and i feel like they just sort of
dismissed it as well it's not a big
hyped-up disney lion king aladdin beauty
and the beast sort of release it's this
legacy character it's based on a goof
troop this is more like a made for tv
thing than anything else and they just i
in my opinion i feel like the tomato
meter just kind of looked at this movie
and it's like oh this is just the thing
for kids and just kind of shoveled it to
the side and when you go back and watch
it holy crap because i saw this movie
for the first time at danny's behest as
an adult when i finally sat down and
watched it gave me all of the emotion in
the right place where the father-son
relationship really hit me hard and so i
never looked at goofy's the villain
because i saw this movie as an adult for
the first time so i was just looking at
all those punk-ass teenagers just just
just help your dad your dad loves you
just it just your dad is suffering max
just throw him a bone once he's a
freaking dog throw him a bone once in a
while so we're all on the same page
we're going to be defending a goofy
movie before we get into our movie talk
segment let's turn it over to our expert
youview creation manager tim ryan who is
uh the rotten tomatoes stalwart he sort
of uh looks at all the reviews of the
critics at the time of the movie's
release and tells us what they were
saying when this film came out initially
in april way back in 95.
[Music]
disney's theatrical features the little
mermaid beauty and the beast aladdin and
the lion king might have won all the
awards in critical praise but the late
80s and early 90s saw another
development in disney animation the
studio started dusting off its most
iconic characters for the small screen
with scrooge mcduck and duck tales
donald and daisy duck and quack pack and
huey dewey and louie in both even mickey
got a new short with runaway brain in
1995 although that one played in
theaters goofy was especially busy the
series goof troop debuted in 1992 and
ran for two seasons it was spun off into
a 1995 theatrical feature simply titled
a goofy movie and in 2000 it got a
straight to video sequel an extremely
goofy movie each of these explored the
relationship between goofy who was very
goofy and his son max who is not the
critics largely found a goofy movie to
be reasonably amusing with a few solid
gags but more like an extended tv
episode than a feature a goofy movie is
61 on the tomato meter with 28 reviews
and it has a 70 audience score so what
did the critics have to say in a fresh
review jackie potts from the miami
herald wrote
wisely this fast-paced movie has enough
colorful characters and rollicking gags
to keep the tikes from getting bored
however in a rotten review stephen
holden the new york times wrote a goofy
movie is engaging in its mild-mannered
way but the story is too rambling and
emotionally diffused for the title
character to fully come alive the rotten
tomatoes critic's consensus reads a
goofy movie offers enough of its titular
ingredient to satisfy younger viewers
even if most parents will agree that
this beloved character deserves better
so that's a goofy movie let's kick it
back to jacqueline and mark who've spent
this segment contemplating why it is
that goofy is a dog but pluto is also a
dog
back to you folks i was literally
thinking that tim you took the words
right out of my mouth because they had a
dog and then they're like we're just
gonna keep pluto as a dog and we're
gonna give goofy we're gonna put funny
skis and stuff on goofy but you you did
have pluto there already see i
definitely living in our current climate
definitely understand the dichotomy
between goofy and pluto because that's
just like remember some of the
collective things we got everyone to do
during this like time and certain people
didn't i feel like pluto are those
people they're the people where you hand
them shoes and say walk and they're like
you know what i'm just gonna be a dog i
don't really wanna slick i don't wanna
grow up that's exactly who those people
are so the goofy people are the people
that are like we're gonna do this
together goofy as it were and the pluto
people are like all fours
danny you go to disneyland on a on a
regular basis is pluto still a presence
at disneyland or is it all goofy uh no i
think they still have pluto i don't see
either i see goofy more i think they
still have pluto though i feel like but
i was gonna say the wild thing that
happened a couple years ago was this
massive like meme i think on reddit
about maribel the cow because she's so
similar to goofy and i think that
there's like they might have dated or
something so everyone was like is
maribel a dog or a cow she's a cow very
clearly but
that's like a whole i'm way into it
i'm way too in
i'm i'm way too into all of this
i know too much disney that's what
happens when you become a disney
character they give you a big bible and
you get to know
it's like when you're the president with
like jfk and
don't give that a ufos i interview those
people they barely know their
character's names
they give you a whole bible and you get
to find out all the secrets you get to
see the walt disney head cryogenic head
you get all of that you're the only one
that read it you're the only one that
read it
you get to go to the vault and actually
witness walt down there like austin
powers so all right let's move on to
movie talk let's get into this
everything that we can gush about with a
goofy movie
yeah i i really don't understand some of
these critic reviews danny because
there's a critic i won't name the critic
but at the time this movie came out they
said that a goofy movie was a disney
quickie without any heart and i feel
like the one thing that if you want to
lob some criticisms at this for being
breezy or not even being a
technically a feature because it's only
70 minutes fine have at it this movie is
so full of heart though and so i i feel
like that's it's it wears it on its
sleeve like how could you not see that
this movie is full of heart
i'm just curious for your perspective on
this danny as a child when you first
came across a goofy movie and if you
look at it the same way now as an adult
no i mean like i said i think that i
switched uh i started to side with goofy
i think the older you get especially as
your parents get older you know and
there's such a complicated relationship
there and you think like yeah i was uh
rebellious when i was a teen that's
super universal and common but you just
when you go back and watch this it's
like this dad was doing the best that he
could and he just loved his son and he
says that repeatedly that he just wants
to be a part of his life and really
touching heartwarming
moments i was gonna say this this i
almost feel like i would normally say
when someone gives a review like that
like were they on their phone
but there weren't phones back then so i
don't know
what they were busy
playing tetris or something i don't know
mario 64.
and wasn't paying attention to
how much heart but aside from the heart
i do want to say go back to
the soundtrack i mean they really didn't
have to snap like that and they did for
the fact that you know we talk about uh
iconic soundtracks like the lion king uh
like aladdin and stuff um but to this
just was so 90s in such a perfect way
and it's such a pump up jam and like
they did a perfect uh nod to prince and
michael jackson and tevin campbell is
just wow this is how i know kevin
campbell by the way
really through a goofy movie uh-huh oh
my god so i will just say that um i have
to add this uh this was written by
carter burrell who is a very like he was
like an indie uh rock hit sort of
producer so think of that very sort of
like
live verve people type time frame that's
what he was doing during that time as he
was kind of doing that but he was also a
composer and lyricist and his first job
was actually working with coen brothers
he did blood simple he did miller's
crossing he did fargo and in between all
of that he did a goofy movie and all of
these like big popcorn things because i
think he was just like a struggling
musician so like literally you're
getting a guy
who would go on to win oscars and like
be nominated for oscars for movies like
carol and three billboards outside of
ebbing missouri and he literally is also
composing this and he's composing this
in homage to howard ashman who died in
1991
doing beauty and the beast and so this
movie is literally a 90s kids version
of belle of a beauty and the beast the
soundtrack really impressed me because i
still they still played at my gym
sometimes like like in the morning and
when you're doing the early 6am workout
and you're trying to lift then you need
some power line and it does wake you up
and it's a great companion to what the
rest of this movie is and as i alluded
to before this came out in 95 and so i
was sort of like if this movie was goofy
then i was max at the time because
that's right when i was like 14 or 15
and i'm like i'm too cool for disney
like disney's for kids and i want to be
like a cool adult i want to get into
other stuff and so you just totally
dismissed this movie when it came out
and i never paid it any mind and then
you get older and that's just sort of
how you have it in in your brain is that
this is a kid's thing and i'm an adult
and i just miss this time window you
know it's it's like i caught on with ren
and stimpy and rocco's modern life and
that might have been the last sort of
animated fair that i cared about until i
grew up a little bit and i looked back
and i was like oh that's some really
good stuff but a goofy movie always fell
through the cracks until danny's like no
you need to see this movie and then when
i saw it i was so surprised at how
emotional i got at the there's a scene
early on where where goofy is so clearly
just trying to relate to his kid and he
just wants max to be his buddy and
because goofy's a lonely guy like goofy
goofy needs a friend and you're not as a
parent maybe you shouldn't rely on your
kid to be your best friend but goofy
just wants to bond and he went on this
fishing trip to idaho with his dad and
so now he just wants max to have the
same thing but max is doing the same
crap i was doing where you're too cool
for your parents you want to drop you
off a block away from school when when
you're going to the dance and nobody
sees you and they just think you rode
there on a magic carpet i guess and he's
trying to press roxanne and then we're
off on this adventure and it really did
the movie touched me the alphabet soup
scene really gets me danny what's the
scene for you that you still think of
every time you watch a goofy movie and
you're like that that is the best scene
in this movie yeah i think the high dad
soup would go against any anybody that
says this doesn't have heart is if you
don't cry during that scene you don't
have a heart i mean
uh it's it's um so sweet he's he's
basically goofy is saying when when max
was little he used to write little
things in the alphabet soup and one of
them was hi dad and
[Music]
[Laughter]
it's just so sweet and and so they're
fighting and they're not speaking to
each other and he hands him a cup and it
says hi dad and it's just
so sweet
it's even better than jack when it's
even better than the end of field of
dreams like the heyday want to have a
catch it's even better than that
well
we might as well get some shut eye
i don't think we're going anywhere
tonight
[Music]
that moment absolutely for sure but the
father-son
song as they're floating on
that's it for me like when they finally
anything that's great is great if you
can then put it to song i'm even more
like down for it also little fun fact on
this one the voice of max
bill farmer did goofy um who i think
voiced goofy like just a ton anyway from
the cartoons and jim cummings was there
too they basically had like the roads
like i would say like the murderous row
of like voice actors even you know polly
shore who pops up both in this
but also in the goofy tv show which i
also feel like needs a bigger like play
in the sun which was the tv show that
ran on disney plus that i used to watch
every morning it was aladdin and goof
troop like like right right next to each
other like i loved it but jason marsden
uh who also voiced it thackery banks
from hocus pocus so like this was like a
part of that disney channel when they
were just turning out these movies with
like the same people sometimes they were
like direct-to-video versions and i
think that's what people thought with
this like this they thought this was the
return of jafar they thought this was
tarzan too they thought it was and those
are movies that actually i think predate
this but it's this idea not tarzan too
anyway it's this idea of like taking the
popular thing and then doing a direct to
video release and they thought that's
what goof
goofy movie was and they thought that's
what this was about and it wasn't and i
think that's like where a lot of the
the hate kind of came from it well they
also wanted a more human i mean disney
wanted to have a more human emotional
uh resonance with goofy because if you
think about him as a character i mean
all those uh
all those like uh driving video remember
the ones from the 50s the old like psa
goofy um and so you never you only see
this character being a clown and so you
don't ever see like his emotional i mean
that's what disney's known for is kind
of like gutting you uh ever since like
bambi you know gutting you with like
emotional um scenes
and
uh so i think that was very smart of
them to show a human side of this
character max by the way was just the
coolest i don't know anyone that didn't
have a crush on him i had a massive
crush on him also had a crush on roxanne
but very open about that i mean they
were just like how can we how can we get
like t it's funny mark that you didn't
watch it as a teen because i think they
definitely went into it with like how
can we get teens how can we get young
people and also if you watch it as an
adult it resonates with as an adult as
well i mean i'm glad i didn't see it as
a teen because because roxanne might
have done weird things to me you know i
mean
just like jessica rabbit roxanne i put
her up there with jessica rabbit
you've actually been roxanne for
halloween yeah i actually was roxanne
also on our friend hal rugnik he has a
competition called tournament of nerds
at ucb and i competed as roxanne and won
my round that was great it was so fun to
play her i'll have to post when this
episode comes out i'll post uh pictures
of me but i also you guys at the 25th
anniversary at el capitan uh this was
before the pandemic everybody dressed up
and went out was all out and i knew
everybody was gonna be max or roxanne so
i went as lisa she is the hot blonde who
says who's that guy
and i went as her and everybody actually
won the competition or at least i
remember i like was a finalist because i
was i was only competing against myself
like nobody thought to dress like her
and she's hot i wore like hoop earrings
and this hot black crop top she wore i'm
like this is a i love this style i could
wear this to the club and i did that's a
good that's a good pro tip for for
cosplayers like if you're doing like an
event like that go with the off-brand
character don't dress because that's
that's always my fear going to a
halloween party because i'm not that
original or creative as you two already
know from dealing with me so i'm just
worried i'm gonna have like the
crappiest batman costume but if you pick
something that's like original and that
nobody else is gonna do but they'll
still know
and lisa is perfectly in that wheelhouse
as i would also say jacqueline alluded
to this character is paulie shore's
bobby uh i believe it's bobby uh
zamerski who creates the leaning tower
of chisa and i didn't know that paulie
my close personal friend now was in the
movie and so i'm watching it for the
first time and i hear paulie's voice and
i'm like oh crap but it's the perfect
timeline to have paulie shore in there
that because he's super hot off of
encino man and son-in-law and in the
army now and all the and all of his like
run of movies biodome and stuff like
that it's great to have paulie short in
addition to all the other disney stuff
so it's not just like this father-son
feel-good movie you also get to like
follow a fun group of high school
teenagers jaclyn i mean yeah that's the
best part of it is it goes back to this
idea of when you were a kid in the 90s
and so many of those things if you
happen to be kids in the 90s brings you
back to it danny you did not like glass
on this enough this was a microcosm of i
think a version of high school that was
both authentic but still not depressing
like there was just enough angst and
there was just enough comedy but there
was just enough absurdity for it to feel
separate from what you were dealing with
but still completely universal and and
relatable the thing that's interesting
about it now is like just the little
things it shows the absurdity of
cassette tapes um big shoulder pads like
all of the very 90s things that we
obviously know about but if you mention
it to someone now about the fact that
like literally the the cassette tape
would start like fitting out at you like
the string that is not something that
you get when you just stare at a
cassette tape now as a gen z person and
the the the high school dynamics like
even discussing lunchroom politics and
things like that like all of that stuff
was there and i loved it no it's so
funny there's in classic disney fashion
because this is being made by adults
there's adult humor in there so uh and
also lester's possum park i have to give
a shout out to lester's
making fun of the chuck e cheese
animatronics i mean
that whole scene is so comedic so funny
uh my brothers used to he's smack he's
like don't hug me to the big uh possum
mascot and he hits him and says beat at
doofus and my brothers and i would say
that to each other so
much but yeah there's a there's a ton of
comedy in this so it it is entertaining
as an adult to watch it and still see
some of those uh adult jokes that are in
it as well and we learned something
about adulthood
through goofy's eyes and that is the
office bully the person who you're going
to grow up and you're going to have i
remember my high school basketball coach
would always say that you're going to
doesn't matter what kind of work you go
into you're going to have to deal with
sharks and we get the classic shark boys
by jim cummings who is pete goofy's
nemesis for for decades in in one form
or another and so here he's goofy's
co-worker who always tries to it one up
him and his bo and he's got the best
camper and and his his son and goofy son
are really good buddies and so that's
sort of how pete finds out that max lied
to roxanne and is trying to steer goofy
towards la so then go see powerline and
that dynamic is also something that i
found really rewarding in this movie was
goofy not just trying to reconnect with
his son and form a lasting bond but it's
also danny it's the challenge of goofy
trying to one-up pete and sort of
getting a leg up and not being the uh
the the office you know the the the nerd
of the office anymore mark did this
remind you this father-son dynamic and
the bullying remind you of any movie
that travels back in time
it's a little back to the future and
right watching your dad be bullied yes
and your dad's kind of like this nice
pushover like goofy nerdy dude um who
actually does stand up to him but also i
want to say pete is a cat i'm keeping
track of all the animals
so classic dog cat rivalry yeah but yeah
we all remember being kids in the rich
kid the rich kid got the playstation the
rich kid got he had a pool
and you had like the blow up pool
and generational family trauma that was
built up by that wealth but never
coddled through actual emotional
intimacy yeah we got that
see look at all it's doing the levels i
don't know get off your phone when
you're watching this movie and pay
attention to
the care that they put
and um
and one one final thing i wanted to say
is jacqueline circling back to the
music not just talking about kevin
campbell but you were talking about the
composer is that um that scene when
the scene on the river um after that
song has such great like it's the
music's so emotional the swell it's like
very jarring um they it's a
life-or-death situation actually that
goofy saves his son life and then his
son saves his life and i just like also
cried during that scene and they embrace
and it's just like wow i'm
i'm in awe of this movie i i really do
have to talk i'm gonna give this moment
like a lot of people know carter barrel
and i hate that this is what he's known
most for which is twilight but say what
you will about twilight that bella's
lullaby is a bop bop bop and a half okay
so like they knew how to make songs
there's a reason why those are the what
plays underneath the tick tocks and
everybody knows it's twilight because
it's catchy but this man did carol
another movie about huge unrequited love
you know like roxanne barely speaks in
the movie let's be real it's mostly like
max like staring off to the side of her
i swear to god the opening of carol
where she sees rooney marta in the hat
that might as well have just been
roxanne when max is like singing his i
want song at the beginning it's like the
exact same thing it is like this is what
i want um this is the guy that
orchestrated the big lebowski so just
imagine him doing something so over the
top as that and then doing something
like this which again i feel like it's
just his sort of like
punk rock alt indie version of beauty
and the beast like finding love because
this is the love story that's the other
thing it is a love story between a
father and a son they fall in love on
this journey it is it happened one night
that is like old school
falling and realizing that this is the
who the person i'm supposed to be with
i.e supposed to be in this case but yeah
it's all there and
that i think goes back to this idea of
like they just dismissed this as
simplistic and didn't see the nuance
that was being layered in of the
absurdity it's the fact that everybody
sings on the song that they're driving
out of town from there's there's a lot
of musical theater i would say license
that they take in this that makes people
dismiss that oh no this was very
deliberate like this was very
purposeful in how we did this and it is
absurd but it has hard underneath it
that's the other thing about this movie
to me is that if you were to make this
competitive and and put all the disney
movies into like a march madness sort of
bracket right then you would have the
lion king would be a number one seed and
cinderella would be a number one seed
and you would have a goofy movie barely
making the field and it would be a
bubble team it would it would get in
there and it'd be like a 12 seed but
this movie could beat anybody in its
path because the lion king and beauty
and the beast and aladdin they're also
they have that like based on a fairy
tale veneer that everybody loves rushing
out to the theater to go see the disney
movie this one came out in april of 95.
and it made its budget back twice over
but it didn't quite crack 40 million
dollars in the united states whereas
your big time disney movies that time
were doing 200 300 million dollars at
the box office so it didn't get that
kind of attention but even though and
and the music was such a signature
disney touch and the music in this movie
is just as good as anything that you'll
see in any other disney movie and my
favorite song in this film is actually
the after today one that they sing at
the beginning when max is like just get
me through if there is a a song that
just encapsulates the teen angst of the
repetitive nature of just i gotta go to
school again today and i to deal with
all the lumps of it there's two songs
that i put above everything else and
it's alice cooper's school's out and
it's after today where it's like just
get me out of here because after today
things are bound to get better because
you're not gonna be in in school anymore
that's the one that does it for me that
just and it really sets the tone for the
movie with max's feeling and he's just
on emotional overload danny what's the
song in here that you find yourself most
responding to uh i guess i still love
eye to eye we actually in my um dance
team frisco high school in frisco texas
i was on the dance team there and we did
a dance to both standout and eye to eye
i think we were like so again we're like
pushing this movie so hard even back
then that we like made our instructor
like let us do it uh i think for our
spring show
but if you listen to the lyrics it's
like so
hard you know about coming together and
just like leading with love and i just i
was just listening to it this morning
when i was getting ready and i'm like
god i just
i hope more people i'll be more young
people i'm going to introduce it to my
niece and nephew because i just need
more young people to
uh
hear it i think yeah i mean knowing that
how much you and your brothers watch
this movie i imagine your brother's
doing a pretty good job raising the
kiddos with with a goofy movie in their
hearts uh jacqueline your
take on the best song in a goofy movie i
mean i guess i already kind of gave it
through it's the best song it's the best
thing but nobody else but you like it's
a lot it's like it's danny will be
driving around and danny has the i
believe danny still has the full
soundtrack and it just comes on and
that's when the volume knob goes up
right oh it's i mean it's perfect pump
up when you're getting ready uh karaoke
i want to say it's great for karaoke
great for working out i mean there's no
you can listen to this soundtrack for
anything
and i mean anything also though i will
say uh the singing voice for max is not
the same as the speaking voice they have
a different one uh the uh bill farmer
did both but
i was kind of surprised by that because
i thought that was his voice i didn't
realize it was somebody else singing
which i'm always like sad about that uh
you did talk about the box office mark i
want to remind everyone disney was
gearing up for pocahontas like
pocahontas gets released like three or
three months after this movie and i
think that also is people's minds is
because
you know anything about a disney release
if by when this movie is coming out
they decided to
they were promoting the other movie
already so it was almost like while
you're graduating they're already
talking about your younger sister's
wedding like it's like you know it's
like it's it's not it's not really the
the moment um and honestly i think it's
so funny because
this movie was supposed to be
jeffrey katzenberg's
return to greatness they modeled it off
of beauty and the beast in almost
everything that they did in so many
different ways
and it ended up being the thing that got
him kicked out at disney because it its
failure is what michael eisner used to
kick him out so this is actually
considered the death of a hollywood
executive which i think is very
interesting so the man who made this
movie who put all of his blood sweat and
tears into it miss danny uh it basically
killed him so it was his it was his
white whale i don't know how he feels
about it now seeing how big it is it's
like there's literally merch of it now
that's how much millennials have a say
in things is there's literally
after 25 years they now have merch of
this at disneyland like i said it was
all over target they were like oh you oh
you like this movie oh okay we no we can
do this and they started oh max max is
that california adventure that's a huge
thing not goofy max goof is at my
friends and i saw him they were wearing
a power line shirt he was out there he
was waving so that's huge to me you know
when they normally have like mickey to
have a massive line for people that want
to meet max from a movie that came out
in a show that came out in the 90s like
that's how big we were like no we love
this movie and you need to pay attention
and they were like we hear you and spend
money here please yeah you mentioned the
event that you attended at the el
capitan celebrating the 25th anniversary
i didn't realize this but i was at d23
in 2015 when they did the 20th
anniversary and it was a big deal that i
know i think jim cummings bill farmer
jason um marsden pauly sure would send a
video message i think and so they did
like a big event and but again it just
gets overshadowed by something because
obviously everybody was at d23 wanting
to see star wars stuff because the force
awakens was coming out later that year
and i didn't also realize this is that a
goofy movie opened back in 95 it opened
at number two
at the box office do you know what movie
what classic buddy cop movie opened at
number one that same weekend
looking
for bad boys bad boys opened it that's
hard to go against
that was that was will smith and martin
lawrence uh teaming up and defeating
goofy but then there was also kevin
campbell uploaded a couple of videos in
2016 of him doing songs with the band
enfield and they and they did i2i and
they did stand out and so this stuff
just continues to have legs danny do you
see a future where a goofy movie can
sort of bear more fruit or do you think
that it's just going to be this cultural
touchstone from the 90s that maybe a few
generations guam onto but we never
really do anything new with oh no
there's definitely uh gonna be goofy
stuff in the future i know that they
that that ip has been asked about i know
because i asked about it
i have no i have really good reps and
they were like this person who i can't
name has already claimed it but you know
things shift and move and with the
pandemic and like we said uh disney and
marvel's star wars like all of their
track of things that they're trying to
put out right now but i can guarantee
you
that this ip will continue on that i do
know that jaclyn that's what i love
about danny is that when she got to have
that meeting with walt disney's frozen
head the one question she asked is like
hey what are we doing with the goofy
movie is there anything new going on
i really do like danny stop
i mean look they let you in the house
they can't be mad if you're starting to
set up furniture as i say all the time
listen
mark knows
mark knows uh that's the nice thing
about working to the level that i've
gotten at that now whenever i ask about
something my people are like oh yeah
let's let's set up something with you
and that y'all comes from a decade of
working in this business no um
so danny and i i think we're about like
nine or ten years apart jack and i are
two or three years apart there seems to
be this divide between early 90s the big
disney blockbusters and the late 90s
disney blockbusters i'm obviously on
team early 90s and i'd say my favorite
blockbuster the 90s from disney was it's
i want to say a lion king but it just
feels like that's such an easy answer
but but beauty and the beast and aladdin
for robin williams performance are way
up there too what's your favorite what's
y'all's favorite 90s disney movie is it
early 90s or is it late 90s disney well
depends on what you mean when you say
ask that you mean disney movie all
together in general every iteration are
you talking about disney the
blockbusters the the big big releases uh
nothing beats lion king like i i'm
saying this as someone that grew up with
every single birthday i was a different
disney princess my parents literally
like with aladdin i was jasmine they had
uh
i grew up in the 90s when they would
have uh these girls that would come they
would dress up as the princess or
whatever and do your makeup and stuff
and so that that's the birthdays that i
would have i had a bell i had a little
mermaid i had and all of these disney
princesses still gotta go with lion king
most iconic soundtrack like also
just heartwarming um crushes your heart
then picks it back up
i don't think there's anything more
iconic that also just the animation that
opening scene i remember when they
released that the trailer like it's just
the most iconic 90s disney movie well i
lost money in vegas then jacqueline
because i bet on danny saying hercules
i'm out that's not to say well that's
kelly's is also sorry go ahead i'll just
say that's my choice because like i love
the lion king i really do love the lion
king and it's not just because they have
women narrate black women narrating the
plotting and as a one as a black writer
i'm like of course i'm home literally
i'm trying to narrate all the movies
that i'm watching that did not enlist a
black woman to be a part of that process
so i love that they just gave me that
off the get um no it is hercules for me
i'm not even saying that i think
hercules is better than lion king better
than aladdin or better than little
mermaid but there is something about
hercules that i just
love i love that it hits
more things about disney that i like now
as an adult than it did when i liked it
as a kid i think if you're asking me
which one of those movies did i like
from that time period i would definitely
say beauty and the beast like at that
time
nothing topped beauty and the beast for
me and probably still to this day in a
lot of ways but legitimately hercules it
just hits me different it hits me
different of the like
wanting someone to be proud of you girl
there's a whole line with phil about
like him being like that's phil's boy
and like that but there's also something
about like hercules wanting him wanting
his
father to be proud of him and there's
the broken girl inside of me that
therapy is helping to repair that just
like it hits differently than the girl
who's like i want to find a man yeah
well also the muses yeah the muses
and meg is more of the perfect like i
like stories with slightly broken women
anyone that knows me like the apartment
heathers are my two favorite movies like
look at the center characters of that
one not exactly got their together but
that's why hercules hits me different is
because she's like literally her love
song is about how much she doesn't want
to be in love and if that is that and
how she can't stand men yeah i was like
seen represented okay so jack jacqueline
likes liberty bell women where where you
can see the cracks you can see there
there's flaws
but but but we're still whole we're
we're still still we're we're still
slightly broken women because these like
together happy [ __ ] i'm sorry i'm
very confused
mark knows that i went to greece
recently with my friend cheyenne wulu
and we were playing the hercules
soundtrack so much and i'm like they're
probably so annoyed with us also know
when greek was involved
but we went to the parthenon and like i
saw like you know the muses i saw the
god the gods and god and i was like yes
this is just like what i grew up with
um so yeah actual gods and goddesses
looking down they're like really we're
just disney i understand russell crowe's
pain in the new thor movie i get it yeah
i feel you zeus i'm with you because i
grew up in colonial williamsburg for a
time and i was there when pocahontas was
released the same year as a goofy movie
and everybody was spawning over
pocahontas and us in williamsburg were
like that's not how it went down at all
so we were we were not fans in colonial
williamsburg of pocahontas but we are
talking about the one particular disney
movie a goofy movie and it still stands
the test of time maybe not in terms of
box office at the era in which it was
released but ever since it's taken on a
life of its own and is still out there
today an extremely goofy movie not as
beloved just kind of there and existing
but who knows maybe you'll get another
iteration and a proper sequel to a goofy
movie sooner rather than later and with
that we are going to transition to our
mailbag let's open it up ryan
[Music]
always nice to have some high dad soup
in the morning so this is from our
ketchup crew member ben norris y'all can
be like ben any time you want just email
us rotten tomatoes is wrong that's rt is
wrong at rotten tomatoes
rottentomatoes.com
and you can give us your thoughts on
what movies do you think we should be
talking about or if you heard an episode
and you had some feelings share them
right there ben is emailing us from
northamptonshire in the uk and ben says
love the show and listening to all the
back episodes has kept me entertained
upon many an hour in terms of brad pitt
films which we recently covered he has
some absolute stinkers according to ben
seven years in tibet which was about
seven years long
that's fair the devil's own just for the
accent alone and meet joe black i wish i
hadn't
saying that he did make seven and
glorious bastard so he has redeemed
himself many times over keep up the good
work and thank you from ben norris yeah
that brad pitt episode has really made
the rounds there jacqueline uh i'm going
to ask danny in a minute for her
favorite brad pitt movie if she has one
but as far as brad pitflicks like we
talked about the legends of the fall to
meet joe blacks of the world i actually
went back and i saw legends of the fall
again it was on tv the other night
you just get sucked up in it you just
get wrapped up in the story yeah no i
don't disagree with you also
he said uh the devil zone for the accent
alone fair but i would counter back meet
joe black for the accent alone brad pitt
does a patois in meet joe black which is
the greatest cringe-worthy awesomeness
that i have ever seen i have a counter
to that i have a counter to that now
we had a fan that is from the region and
they wrote that i think we thought it
was a jamaican accent but he was
actually doing some sort of it was like
a particular caribbean accent and
according to this fan who who wrote us
and they said that he did a dead on no
that's right
no he did a dead-on impression but he is
still white as crystalline doing it so
like that's fair
that's fair commitment doesn't
necessarily make it better
i'm not saying it should have been done
but i'm just saying i'm going to give
i'm going to give our fan credit for
pointing that out so thank you
for pointing out that brad pitt who's
from who checks notes is white did a
very good pat swan once upon a time in
meet joe black white from the ozarks
dude yeah ozarks like his like literally
ozarks
very white that's what he's bringing
even though he's got a very good tan
with those abs uh danny do you have a
favorite brad pitt movie on the top of
your head yeah i guess my favorite movie
that he's in is ocean's eleven uh that
movie is just still holds up watched it
recently it always like tickles me as a
writer of like how can i create
something that's as cool as this and has
this large ensemble love that he
committed to eating in every single
scene i mean just as an actor it's just
fun to to play but i do have to say i
think one of his earlier roles that
really was like wow was interview with a
vampire uh was just like whoa who you
know was still being introduced to him
and it's just like who is this
man i think i just grew up seeing him in
tabloids because a lot of his films i
couldn't watch when i was little
including that one including an
interview with a vampire um and so i
just always knew him as uh
rachel what's her name from friends why
am i blanking richard
no from friends his wife jennifer oh
jennifer
oh i always just knew him as jennifer
people are going to laugh i just knew
him as jenner jennifer aniston's husband
um and then angelina jolie's husband um
but yeah a lot of his you know like i
said i'm a 90s kid so a lot of his films
i could not see
uh but when i did finally see interview
with a vampire i was like whoa he really
showed up i thought he was a great actor
in that but yeah ocean's 11 for my
favorite film that he's in interview of
the vampire came out uh five months
before a goofy movie was released so
that is gonna do it for us here today on
rotten tomatoes is wrong a
an episode for all times kids because
we've been wanting to do a goofy movie
we've been wanting to have danny
fernandez on forever danny it was a
pleasure to have you join us uh there's
a there's a snoring i would say roxanne
that is right at my feet right now her
name is molly the wonder dog i know you
are uh friends with her as well as i you
are the mother of molly the wonder dog
you first adopted her way back when you
were in college i was a teenager
yeah
and she's still you all have had so many
adventures together do you sort of look
at yourself as maybe the goofy to her
max
wow yes she is very irritated by me at
all times although she's older than me
she's a gold she's like in her 90s so
she's technically my elder i feel like
she's a an
old frosted face lady that i have to
take care of every day and give like
applesauce too so
she's she's definitely ma from the
golden girls uh danny where can
everybody find you out there i know you
have so much stuff in the oven so many
things you can't quite talk about just
yet but uh what's the good the social
media for for everybody to go find you
yeah so i'm on twitter and instagram at
miss danny fernandez it's ms
d-a-n-i-f-e-r-n-a-n-d-e-z i still have
my pride comic that dropped in june uh
there's a great harley quinn cover this
is pride dc 2022 you can call your local
comic book shop if they're out because a
lot of them sold out
but there's an amazing cover by jen
bartel that has harley quinn and poison
ivy i wrote a
love story of them
that is
very fun uh that's in there so yeah you
can pick that up at your local comic
book shop uh once again you can email us
anytime rt is wrong at
rottentomatoes.com whatever you do to
support your favorite podcast do it for
us you can subscribe rate review
whatever your preferred platform asks
you to do go ahead and do that and we
could get more guests like danny
fernandez in the future talking about
beloved films like a goofy movie films
that have been wronged by the tomato
meter because it's just barely fresh
it's 61 percent we think it should be
way way higher this was an absolute
pleasure thank you so much for joining
us danny make sure you find her at miss
danny fernandez and all the wonderful
things she's doing for the entire crew
here producie lucy
expert engineer brian perez our review
curation manager tim ryan jack with coy
my wonderful co-host and once again to
the great danny fernandez molly the
wonder dog who just woke up i am merely
mark ellis and it doesn't matter what
kind of a week you've been having kids
just remember that after today things
are bound to get better
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]